nestled in the middle of the
up-and-coming neighborhood of eagle rock
california is capri an italian
restaurant which is owned by the field
twins
hi i'm jeff
hey i'm jack no i'm jeff you're jim i'm
jim
and we're the owners of the capri
italian restaurant
good evening capri jim speaking
how we got into the restaurant business
was we used to camera all the time and
we loved the place so we'd said we'll
buy it the feeling was it's like dude
free pizza all right yeah yeah word word
uh-huh team capri the twins are like two
overgrown boys
jeffy's getting larger
let's play symbols
they're
just kind of immature oh i show you how
you do the chicken fillets
excuse me they're just doing what they
know
and it's not working
sorry are you
sorry
it's okay
yes everybody is entertained by their
childishness
but it is a restaurant and we're here to
serve food
that looks good
you know what these guys can't cook
we're gonna figure a better way to do
the lasagna we're getting too many
people saying it's overcooked you think
we should cook it less
the food that comes out in the kitchen
looks terrible
what do you say it wasn't cooked it's
raw okay i want them all it's
embarrassing it looks like nobody cares
you sure you don't like raw chicken
here they're an issue jim and jeff are
lazy all right i'm going to the car wake
me up when it's over
lazy is an understatement the twin's
highest priority is doing as little work
as possible
[Music]
there's something that we're doing wrong
i'm not sure what it is
but in the financial situation hit the
pooper we're broke
oops that pink is never a good color i
haven't paid them for a few months
we need help if things don't change
i would say the doors will close quickly
hello
no the phone's not working again
fingers crossed that chef ramsay's gonna
help us
[Music]
capri italian dining since 1963.
closed since 1963
my god
hideous
hello
hi there
how are you pretty good i'm jeff good to
see you good to see you likewise uh
it looks sharp from outside uh yeah
we're not open yet are you not open yet
no when do you open uh four o'clock
dinner only yeah and you're the uh owner
yeah my brother and i are okay great
would you like to be my brother uh yes
please what's his name jim jim
and you're jeff yep
oh my god look at this place
okay
just say hey how's it going oh no it's
fun to play jokes on people in the twin
union book you gotta mess with people
hey how's it going
jeff is your brother not available no
i'm jim
no come on no i miss brother
you're kidding me no i am seriously i am
serious
jeff go get jim come on don't listen all
right i've got work to hold on please
hold on hold on i'll get him
what is this the comedy store
bloody hell look at them
are you kidding me come on guys
jeff and jim yeah correct
[Music]
look at you two
you are identical
you're not dressing like this especially
today this is we were this as this is
for the rest we've even got the same
sneakers
pen there pen there i didn't even notice
this t-shirt there t-shirt there i
didn't know this bit of flower there bit
of flower there yep it's quite scary
jim yep and jeff yep so who's in charge
no uh basically i am i've worked here
longer than he has okay uh what since
1963 come on
no no we bought it about 14 years ago
okay so why aren't you open for lunch
[Music]
the capris never opened for lunch which
is good
i'd rather go on the computer watch tv
play poker the problem is for lunch we
have to get another whole staff
goof off
sit in the sun
you haven't even tried it no i haven't
no i'm not ready to jump into the lunch
yet
okay but you open every day for dinner
wednesday through sunday
say that again wednesday through sunday
what's wrong with monday tuesday
so help me understand this okay right so
you're actually
closed longer than you open yeah
ready
okay well thanks for updating me i'm
gonna sit down and eat please yeah right
over here thank you let me get you have
some water i'll get the water
no i'll get the water
yeah
jeez seriously are these menus from 1963
as well no they're getting old i know we
have to get you're kidding me but look
at that is this a joke no it's not
you're kidding i believe they're
they're falling apart
you can't even read that it's so dirty
first impressions
wow okay give me five minutes have a
read of the menu okay
and i'll i'll catch up with you guys
later yeah okay
holy crap i don't know what chef ramsey
expected but it's not a shishy place i'm
not a shishi kind of guy i'm more down
to earth
hello oh hello how are you colleen i'm
your server today okay nice to see you
colin how long have you been here nine
and a half years
a decade
yeah seriously what was the last thing
we got changed in here
oh
this is still the same way the rigid
owners had it
wallpaper's been up there for 35 years
oh my god
let's uh let's go through the menu yeah
let's start off with um meatball
sandwich i love meatballs who makes them
they come from a company that we order
from
and you're kidding me
no
can you make a meatball
i can
okay let's go for a meatball sandwich
and let's go with the chicken scalpel
okay pizza oh let's go for the uh capri
colossal you want the big one yeah why
not okay okay i'll let you put that
order in okay thank you you're welcome
okay what do we have to make chicken
scar pillow meatball sandwich extra
large colossal he wants an extra large
jim get me an extra large dough what
does he want a colossal
alrighty
so it's not just the menus
oh dear
there's a sauce down there crap
ugh
just disgusting bits
everywhere let's tape on the carpet
look at this place when was the last
time the place was cleaned not lately
how long have this stuff been here 20
years 20 years
bloody hell
oh it's like it's
snowing oh oh my god that's gross no
yes that's above people's very yes jim
two seconds please
when was the last time this place was
cleaned uh
have you seen this
no i did not my goodness me
who's responsible for cleaning here i'm
responsible i didn't do it
have you seen the fans
i do not like to clean i hate cleaning
to me that's a four-letter word so i'm
about to start eating i give that a
little shake and all of a sudden the
dust just runs down
let me wash my hands before i start
eating what a mess
you wanna microwave these meatballs
please okay
come on work with me
cheese
sandwich is ready
okay
a meatball sandwich meatball sandwich um
[Music]
okay and so they buy the meatballs they
defrost them and then does that mean
microwaved or yes
thank you
okay what else do we have to make a
scarf hello
that's nasty
when the restaurant can't be bothered to
make a meatball that's not a good sign
let me tell you that
somebody should tell him the chicken's
definitely dead
i'm not a kid
[Music]
what's the matter with these guys
[Music]
okay
oh my god
what in the hell is that the colossal
pizza wow
i mean it's like someone's cleared out
the fridge look at it it's endless it
has a little bit of everything except
for anchovies
oh that's dreadful okay thank you okay
the crap and the gun on top of it is
just hideous
he didn't like the pizza
he's not liking anything
oops
[Music]
okay now we have the chicken scarapella
oh
wow
it looks dull
[Music]
that's not right
it smells is that fresh
um
can you ask them how old the chicken is
please
wow that was nasty
how old is the chicken i don't know
when did we get it
uh i don't know
we took it out of the freezer yes 14
years old
we took it out of the freezer yesterday
it's frozen it is not fresh because we
can't afford to keep fresh meat here all
the time because we don't serve that
much if he wants to donate money so i
can make it thrash no problem but
otherwise
tough
they're not open for lunch but so far
what i've just experienced they
shouldn't be home for dinner either he
took out the freezer yesterday and
doesn't
remember when the delivery was
excuse me
oh dear excuse me
i didn't think i was that mad
ugh
under the tables it's littered with gum
colleen yes look at that
it's everywhere
oh
absolutely disgusting how lazy some
people can be
let's go on a gumball rally
oh god under there look the size of the
gum under that one oh look at that one
at the end in the corner
oh my god look at that one there when
was the last time the tables were clean
and that's ever that i've known of
underneath they've never been cleaned
underneath no oh my god one two three
four five one two three four five six
six seven eight nine ten eighteen
nineteen twenty bits of gum
every freaking table has gum underneath
it has gum underneath
reading it out
no
don't say that
come on stop crying
you
uh jim jeff coming i'm really nervous oh
dear steroid right here i'm afraid of
what chef ramsay has to say
honestly
you seem like nice guys but that was
painful
the general feel of the place is
disgusting i can tell how much you don't
care you're standing there with your
foot
on the booth
can you get your dirty feet
off your own boots
have a look at this
every table is littered
with stale disgusting gum
we just we never looked underneath the
table didn't have the time busy for
lunch
open seven days a week not
the meatball sandwich disgusting
the chicken
was turning and then the colossal kate
with crap were they canned mushrooms on
top yeah
canned olives soggy and tasteless
where's the pride i don't know
come on guys
it's like a joke
find a pulse and get real before we open
for dinner tonight would you mind wiping
the lampshade and can somebody get under
the tables and get rid of that gum yeah
i'm going for lunch i'll see you later
starving capri classic italian what a
joke
we said our food sucked
and uh
that uh our restaurant is really filthy
[Music]
it was that bad
[Music]
after sampling the horrendous food
that's not right and discovering a
dining room that hasn't been cleaned in
quite some time oh god under there
chef ramsay has instructed the twins to
clean up the restaurant before dinner
service
you do the fans i don't want to get on a
ladder let's get darion in here i have a
staff to do the cleaning that's why i'm
considered the boss and they are someone
that works with me
for me
get in here now
we don't have a lot of time we have to
turn everything over
we got an hour before we're supposed to
open
after the staff takes over the cleaning
of the dining room capri opens for
dinner hello
and chef ramsay arrives the door shakes
to see the twins in action
have you ever seen a kitchen like this
before
this place is littered with crap
what's that there
co2 for the beer look at those shells
i mean that's grime that's like 14 years
of grime there
chef ramsay was that oh there's dust
here there's this is just like
it's not that bad
what's in here dare i
vegetables that's the vegetables what's
this at the bottom uh that's supposed to
be eggplant
eggplant parmesan when were they cooked
last thursday last thursday
yard almighty look at that
oh feel that something else us you have
a feeling i know it's we just made it
today today so what's it doing in the
fridge
hold that i know it's hot hold it
what does hot things do
that are sealed that goes inside a cold
fridge
the sauce goes sour
i didn't know that you didn't know that
i can suggest you spend five minutes
sorting out you first before you start
cooking yeah okay
i should have known better he's right
but he's just a pain in the ass about it
darren can you go through it real quick
yeah
trash
thank you
with the rotten vegetables thrown away i
need to order wings please and the
order's pouring in
jim and jeff get back to cooking dan
order green beans please
and begin to send food out of the
kitchen make sure they say a prayer
before they start eating that hey the
chicken
i can't eat them but the diners are less
than impressed it's so disgusting
okay
they sent us back they didn't like it
they said that you can't eat it
what was this it was like
[Music]
and a pile of mush
big power mush
is anyone tasting anything seasoning
tasting
every time a dish came back it was like
losing a customer and uh it hurts what
was wrong with it it's too flowery and
not enough sauce
it makes me feel like a loser
i do really feel like a loser right now
jeff
okay
i'm just frustrated
[Music]
[Music]
it's not going right
i need to see what i've got to work with
before i can start looking at any form
of change
you have to bounce back
i'm working on it
i really like jeff you've got to
okay come on okay
let's go [ __ ] okay let's go okay
chef ramsay's right you gotta pull
yourself together and get back in there
and get through the night how are we
doing we're doing well sir
thanks to chef ramsay's encouragement
jeff jumps back into dinner service and
tries to help his brother jim get the
kitchen back on track keep it up jim
you're doing a good job but
unfortunately he only makes matters
worse jim what we've done to those i
don't know what happened to those i i
really don't frosted them in the bag i
think they were defrosted in the bag and
i jeff yeah
the chicken tenders
what did you do to them to defrost them
i put it uh on the steam table you
defrosted them in the steam table from
frozen yeah
oh my
god now what you're supposed to do no
frozen food needs to be defrosted
naturally right
give me the bag where's the bag
oh
god almighty
we can't serve them
you kill somebody
jim talk to me what am i supposed to say
it's a mistake it's a lethal mistake
[Music]
i've been feeling a little bit crap all
afternoon what are you two doing
well what do you want me to say i want
you to step up to the plate and be a man
i screwed up you haven't told anyone yet
he was just being a jerk he was an ass
i'm so tired of him just
pushing and pushing gross
then take it off the menu
i've had enough
i'm so pissed i can only take so much
before i fight that jim get away
it's an hour into dinner service oh god
almighty and chef ramsay has just
discovered a lethal mistake spoiled
chicken at capri you
kill somebody what am i supposed to say
take off the
menu
jim jim
out of the way
ladies and gentlemen
due to certain circumstance we have no
chicken tonight
oh
my apology to everyone here
if you
just want to have what you're eating now
and leave i understand fully and i
apologize
[Music]
hey there may have been a more subtle
way of doing that
get out of my way
when we canceled all our chicken orders
we got screwed will you stop acting like
a baby
me you heard it hey
need diaper changing i'll give you that
time of night little poo poo and cracker
pants
he's the baby he's the one that's
whining over everything i don't need to
hear this
crap dude why don't you have to behave
like this i'm not gonna get you you're
walking around like a big baby and i'm
just asking you to grow up a little bit
show a little bit of respect for what
you're trying to cook
oh my god you big wet noodle you want a
blanket and a bottle do you need one
upside the head
jim
stop come on
what a spoiled wrap
jim shut up please you're not helping
the cause
oh my god now he's setting himself on
fire i hope so
are they always acting like this
childish oh yeah they don't get their
way they crash or throw a temperature oh
my gosh
it's walking the diamond like that and
scream that's what i said temper ketchup
there's a part of me that's very
satisfied to see the boys finally get
what they deserve
pearlescent humility
[Laughter]
okay where are you at now i don't know
i'm sorry but yeah it's really late let
me go check on that for you
can i pass you this they've been here
since we opened and they haven't got
their food yet
some of the tables have been waiting two
hours out there
i know
we don't even seem to be bothered i am
bothered yeah there's only three tables
we said that entrees
come on guys just show a little bit more
infuse at them surely
no it doesn't look good damn it this
can't be happening it's just like a bad
nightmare let's drink our wine
i'm outta here window wants to walk
cancel window customers were not happy
some got tired of waiting and left it
was very disappointing
i'm sorry
[Applause]
it was a bad night
our dishes took longer than usual it was
just an embarrassing night
okay today could be
summed up in one
four-letter word
lazy
i can't even start to help both of you
when you're not helping
yourselves i really need you to do
something
both of you
go through your kitchen
and clean it
now your staff
you
both of you got it yep
good night
get to work
we weren't lazy now we're paying for it
we're failures
yay
i'm just making a turkey here
can i do this what's wrong jim
i can't clean anything i'm a failure i'm
making a mess
i feel bad
we are in trouble i really don't know if
we can fix it that's the problem
go take a break jim
no i can't take a break
because i'm too lazy as it is
[Music]
after the twins spend most of the night
cleaning
chef ramsay arrives early and with the
help of long-time waitress colleen and
pizza maker darian he does something the
twins have never done
open for lunch okay darren yes sir it's
gonna be fast it's gonna be furious but
you can do it okay i'm game for this
how you doing you should come in and
have some lunch
[Music]
i would like the lasagna please
pizza up
let's sign you're up
lasagna enjoy this is delicious
so yeah really good
[Music]
oh look at that
we got a side thriller now open for
lunch
oh cool
what's going on here
oh come on oh wow
i can't believe this is happening
wow
this is our place
hi welcome hi thanks for making it today
thank you uh take a seat feeling a
little bit peckish um
yeah yeah now let me get you a nice
little uh chopped salad huh
this is different let's start off with a
little
oh chopped salad thank you and make sure
you save some room for an italian
sausage lasagna and a very simple
um margarita pizza thank you i'm sorry
excuse me
it's a good pizza
i like it
thank you
okay
whilst you two were home
nice and cozy
i got here early this morning with
darren and colleen i think today we put
over three hundred dollars in the cash
register wow yeah three hundred dollars
if you do that five times a week that's
fifteen hundred dollars that's almost
our rent so it's a lot of money
i'm just
[Music]
very happy
yeah
i had my eyes shut and i was wrong i sat
on my butt being lazy
you can't have your butt stuck to your
bed every morning you've got to get out
and break the mold
message understood loud and clear yep
loud and clear
after finally getting through to the
twins about their laziness chef ramsay
wants to dig a little deeper he has an
unorthodox plan that will allow the
brothers to work out their issues and
their frustrations
time to let go of the past
and to embrace the future
gloves on
i'm not gonna be fighting chef ramsay am
i
i wanna know what's holding you back
want to
oh for god's sake what is that poo what
is that i don't work out this is like
starting an old car after a year sitting
there it's gonna
fart out a little bit
come on what pissed you off the most
what is it
myself
why
huh cause i'm lazy
when was the last time you did something
100
i can't remember
what you afraid of
tell me
screw it up
damn it it's just screwing up
i've done it all my life i'm a failure
you're not a failure
you are not
we all make mistakes in life
embrace
change
[Music]
are you keen to make this business work
yeah it's time i'm ready to move on to
make a success out of this
okay last ten let's go
and again and again come on hit it you
can stop kissing it come on
come on
and again
ready to change
yes good man yeah get the [ __ ] out of
here i know i'm gonna put behind me all
the uh the laziness and look towards the
future and the successes that are coming
jeff
let's go
get us good
nice
it feels good to just let out a whole
bunch of that i've been hanging on to
nice guys nice take a breather good wow
what does this restaurant mean for you
a life a career and you think by sitting
on your lazy ass all day long and
turning up halfway through the day is
going to make it work you need to commit
good you
in here let's go
[Music]
i don't want any headshots just one
round
and tell each other
it's time to work
let's go
we can work together we can work
together
we can be successful we just got to talk
to each other can i keep anything inside
[Music]
[Music]
well done give him a hug
boxing each other uh was a good exercise
because it it cleared the air and it
showed me that it's time for me to work
hard for the business for both of us
okay
good
it's time for change
got it got it are you ready ready good
get cleaned up
meet me back at the restaurants
satisfied that the twins are ready to
make some changes within themselves okay
how you feeling good chef ramsay now
wants to focus on something else that
needs a major change
the food when was that time you made a
meatball probably five years ago yeah
and why did you stop
it was easier
lazy
oops let's make a meatball okay together
it's been a long time since we made
meatballs but i'm ready to do this i am
a professional
right
ground beef season yeah salt and pepper
garlic
handful of chili flakes chef ramsay is a
magician in the kitchen oh you just add
this and this and this and it's just
like
jeff yes how big do you like your
balls ah
pretty good size
i mean you know
golf full size
what
[Music]
a little chase
[Music]
what do you think it's good i like it a
lot can you do that yes can you do that
if you need help yes homemade meatballs
don't eat meatballs the difference is
night and day homemade homemade i can't
hear you oh my god i can't hear you it's
homemade meatball get outside and shout
to the street homemade meatballs tell
them in the neighborhood we have
homemade meatballs i can't hear you we
have homemade meatballs
finally stop we have homemade meatballs
we have homemade meatballs
[Music]
faced with a restaurant that hasn't been
touched since 1963
chef ramsay and his team work overnight
to give this restaurant one of the
biggest makeovers in kitchen nightmare's
history
right good morning good morning you are
in for a big shock
are you ready to see the new capri yes
good on the count of three
one
two
peak
[Music]
three
[Music]
oh my god wow
oh my goodness it's nice just
have a look
we have brought the capri from 1963
fast forward it transformed it to 2011.
it's beautiful look at it cool here this
place is going to be hopping this is
nice oh wow gone is the carpet that was
stuck together with tape you have the
most amazing reclaimed wood
lining the walls look it yeah that's
right we had to put you on the wall as
well colleen what do you think
it's
isn't it amazing it's amazing
we got rid of those hideous green booths
you have the most amazing tailor-made
cut pews as benches from your local
church oh wow sit down at the pew
you're happy yeah like a piggy
yeah
it's great
colleen
come forward darling and bring those
menus from the pocket there
gone are the dirty plastic menus
designed what your kitchen is capable of
producing
so now it's time to stop ignoring the
business and run the business okay yeah
i get nervous when you don't talk
she's totally stunned come on just
amazing
it really is i've never heard you this
quiet i don't have anything what's the
matter just amazing i'm in shock i never
thought i could look so different this
is
beyond what i could ever think could
happen
it's amazing wow
we're moving up and it's exciting
it's the second chance on life
this is gonna be the coolest place in
eagle rock now exactly that
[Music]
come through please look at this oh my
god
let's start off with meatballs
yes what are they
homemade meatballs okay sellers for the
table welcome an italian chopped salad
yay for me the hallmark the pizza the
margarita classic eggplant palm pie
delicious and just gives a completely
different twist
now entrees
baked meat lasagna one of my favorites
yummy
baked herb chicken with fingerling
potatoes and a white wine sauce jim i
like it that's yeah a lot it's cool i'm
jeff that's jim yeah
right little taste yes jump in all right
all the broccoli is so good
the food looks unbelievable and it even
tastes better it's excellent
the eggplant is amazing it's starting to
get full already and i haven't tasted
half the stuff
excuse me
welcome put you right over here please
word of capri's relaunch has spread
through eagle rock we have a new menu we
have great salads and appetizers to
start with and the dining room fills up
quickly with customers eager to try the
new menu you want to do the mac and
cheese the only chicken wing i'll go
grab that and come back to you
all right let's go
there you go jim media margarita pizza
and a baked chicken okay
and i want you to call it out like a
chef okay owner i got two
what is that
hot potato skins two wings yes sir
how are you doing jim
i'm nervous but i have to believe that i
am in charge and i know what i'm doing
own it own it own it yeah yeah don't
leak from the top buddy in spite of
jim's nerves table five is ready pick it
up please food is quickly making its way
out to the diners the high enough
perhaps a little too quickly
hey listen guys guys the chicken's not
hot enough especially inside there
get in the oven get the pan hot first
jim i think he's starting to really get
a little panicky
give me your time with the chicken
please i i got the the chicken in in the
what's in the pan and stuff it's it's
heating up jim bounce back yeah it's not
a race casper's been waiting for good
food hot food out the window i'm
dragging the meatballs forgetting
meatball
is that how i showed you to plate a
spaghetti meatball no it looks like
someone on my plate
jim
come on it's so easy just on and you're
more capable of doing that i'm telling
you it's not rocket science
you can't even grate cheese
stop panicking and focus i'm panicking
right now because we want to get food
out quick
but it's like hey don't screw this up
[Music]
it's an hour into service
and jim is struggling to keep up with
the orders jim how much longer on my
table for it's coming up right now
unfortunately a relaunch that had such
promise
did you really i did not see that looks
like it's slipping away your chicken's
coming also jim look at me what type of
one was that for 16 is there you cutting
it right now i had a mushroom and a meat
lover cut it right up
this is going to 16. they haven't even
got their appetizers
oh
say
god darn it oh come on come in come here
both of you i need you for 30 seconds
all right
oh man we're doing this again i thought
we got through this
please don't let this be the end no no
no no no no no no
it's relaunch night at capri and with
the kitchen backed up jim give me your
time with the chicken please the chicken
in in the what's in the pan and stuff
it's it's heating up and diners waiting
over an hour for food coming both of you
jeff ramsey has seen enough
look at me look at me
right now you're making yourself look
stupid it's a big night tonight yes and
you're pissing it up
so please listen to me you have to
command your kitchen yes you have to
work together but it's not a race
customers are going to wait for good
food stop panicking and focus okay yes
come on chef ramsay was like what
is this
how could
and i go
slip back into our old ways of doing it
and it's like you got to change this is
a new capri
i need to note our garlic nuts and
pepperoni and cheese yes sir go help him
i'll take care of this got it it's time
that i grew up it's time that i start
working as a man and not as a butt head
sausage and bean put some chicken i'm
gonna put base on this right yeah put a
little uh oregano
okay jim good now we're getting a system
convicted yes yeah what's next on 16.
good i got hot food up here please serve
it once we started hitting our rhythm it
was great because things were going out
excuse me we settled down and we got it
zooming along how are we doing so good
the meatballs are our favorite things
this one's really good it's delicious
this is maine from scratch you can tell
this is so amazing it's been one hell of
a roller coaster ride but we've learned
a lot from chef ramsay and he's left us
with a lot of inspiration and hope i can
see that we will make it if we keep
doing what we're doing
jim
jeff
you've come a long way it's been a tough
journey yes
and in order for this place to continue
functioning you both
must work at it yes don't clutter yes
show up early yes lazy is a four-letter
word yes good
god bless you both
okay yeah thank you very much
good luck
we went through a lot to get
you know to get the nightmare into a
dream it's still a learning process but
the future looks really good the capri
is gonna work good luck
god honestly i'm never gonna forget the
twins in eagle rock let me tell you that
thank you good night thank you very much
jeez
yes
wow that was hard
i mean really hard but i now really
believe that both jim and jeff and their
little restaurant can become a huge
tourist attraction here in eagle rock
and come on
who doesn't love a pizza
and a show
oh
that was hard
[Music]
just one month after chef ramsay's
departure can i take a picture of you
two with with jen you sure can
the twins kept their promise and open
for lunch it's excellent it's really
good the new food and decor have made
capri a hot spot in eagle rock come back
again we're gonna keep this gold now
this has been a life-changing experience
thank you very much chef ramsay for what
you did for us i think it's gonna work
it's gonna work by the way we have
homemade meatballs